[Musique]
ce mardi 2 novembre cyrille melchior
président du département s'est rendu à
bras panon il a été accueilli
chaleureusement par jeannick atchapa le
maire de la commune
la visite a débuté au domicile de régime
gazette qui a bénéficié de travaux
d'amélioration de l'habitat
moi j'ai fait la demande de
l'amélioration de l'habitat par rapport
à fille qu elle avait le grand serbe et
les médias nous indiquant moment donné
elle pouvait plus monter et enjamber des
belles tables et loire et où donc c'est
un danger pour la faire monter en haut
tout quand même on s'en sort
mais affirmer à faire aussi
la journée s'est poursuivie à la rivière
du mât les hauts plusieurs habitants du
quartier ont pris part à l'inauguration
de la gare des 48
initialement la route c'était une route
sans pouvoir former l'avion
et donc il a fallu pouvoir proposer une
piste cyclable de parts et d'autres
dernier 75 dollar et des trottoirs
là on n'avait pas beaucoup d'emprise un
seul côté trottoir là où on avait la
possibilité deux trottoirs puis dans les
délais c'est d'y rester deux
aménagements avec la cie
l'embellissement une plantation
symbolique d'espèces endémiques et
indigènes s'est ensuite déroulée devant
le siège de l'office du tourisme de
l'est dans le cadre du plan un million
d'arbres
l'actualité tous les joueurs montent à
noël les images de catastrophes
naturelles montée des eaux
inondations cyclones intense mais il
faut nous prendre soin d'un mètre sur
mes amis élan plante des arbres il n'y a
pas peur des désordres il y à aussi par
exemple réalise que tu marques
automobiles nous des partenaires en
plongée dans une opération d'acquisition
de véhicules électriques aux serristes à
chaque fois que c'est possible et bien
bâti ce manque mais au niveau de
l'amélioration des habitants nous sommes
en train de réfléchir avec janick en
chambre et les autres élus pour que
cannois millions la casse des habitants
de la région je discute avec ces mêmes
habitants sise à tuer une cité à ne
pouvoir récupérer l'eau de pluie pour
arroser le jardin le département est
prêt à s'engager dans cette voie
puis le président du département a remis
au maire les clés d'un kiosque à
vocation économique le cinquième de lui
réalisé par le service défi
développement des filières innovantes du
département ce kiosque est destiné à
accueillir des micro activité économique
avec des loyers modestes n'ont pas lancé
un appel à candidatures de patience que
des portes projet puisse répondre et
nous présenter des projets qui
correspond à l'animation économique
d'une ville ou d'un quartier donné vie à
un quartier c'est aussi implanter des
activités de commerce et d'artisanat
qu'est ce que serait une ville ou un
quartier sans artisanat aujourd'hui la
ville déploie avec la du département un
certain nombre de kiosques à valeur
ajoutera valeur économique pour
permettre l'installation était à vivre
nos quartiers à travers le lien
économique et social donc à l'issue de
cette consultation de son nous aurons un
choix à faire sur le projet qui sera
attribué vous savez que moi je prends de
la proximité la proximité bien
évidemment ce département avec
l'ensemble des domaines des mairies et
ici à bras panon on voit une équipe
mobilisée un maire jadis apathie son
équipe mobilisée autour de projets
d'envergure ou bien évidemment les
routes la culture l'éducation
l'environnement peine toute leur place
et donc notre devoir département c'est
d'accompagner ces projets de cette belle
commune de bras-panon
la journée s'est achevée à la salle
raymond barre où s'est tenue une
présentation originale et théâtralisée
du projet de mélissa et christophe dalot
agriculteurs un projet soutenu par la
cellule d'accompagnement des
agriculteurs du département le venue
présent allure notre projet
d'agroforesterie
de l'agrotourisme et aussi d'enlever à
guillaume culturel et culturels c'est à
dire en fait qu on nous fit ce qu'on
appelle la gauche foresterie nous on
essaie dans une forêt à mener une
culture agricoles cacao vanille mais
aussi d'activités d'apiculture qu'elle
est en lien avec ce monde de forêt
jeannick atchapa clôturer la journée par
la présentation des projets programmés
dans le pst deux dans la signature de la
convention est prévue avant la fin du
trimestre 2022
[Musique]